>> Okay Michael, what's the answer?
>> Does he have spleentitis?
>> Yes, does he have spleentitis?
>> I don't think we know, for sure.
>> Mm? What do mean by that?
>> Well, I mean. It's a noisy and probabilistic world right. So the
test told us that things look like he has spleentitis and the test
is usually right. But the test is sometimes wrong and it can give
the wrong answer and that's really all we know, so we can't be sure.
>> Okay but if you had to pick one. If you had to yes or
no, like our students they did when they took
the quiz. Which one would you pick? Yes or no.
>> So, I guess C the pants. I would just say, yes because the
test says, yes but if I guess I was trying to be more precise, I
may go through and work out the probability and I guess if it's more
likely to have than not to have, then I'd say and otherwise I'd say, no.
>> Okay. So how would you go about doing that? Walk me through it.
>> Based on the name of the quiz, I think I'd go with Bayes' Rule.
>> Okay. So [LAUGH]
I like that. So Bayes' Rule, is everyone recall, is
the probability of the hypothesis given the data is equal to
the probability of the data given the hypothesis times the probability
of the hypothesis divided by the probability of the data. So,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Let's write all that out. So what is the probability of spleentitis,
which I'm just going to write as an s. Given.
>> We're making jokes about spleentitis, but we
don't want that to be confused with splenitis,
which is a real thing and probably not very
pleasant. So apologies to anyone out there with splenitis.
But this is spleentitis, which is really totally different.
>> Is splenitis a real thing?
>> Yeah.
>> :Really what is it?
>> Enlargement and inflammation in the spleen and the spleen as
a result of infection or possibly a parasite infestation or cysts.
>> So what you're saying
is that's gross and we don't want to think about it. OK good so Woo okay, so the
probability of getting splentitis and again is a very rare thing and probably isn't even real.
>> Totally, its totally different, its definitely not real
>> Yea definitely not. Given that we gotten a positive result and you say
that we should use Baye's rules so that would be in this case what?
>> So it's the same as
the probability of the positive result given that you have spleentitis.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Times the probability, the prior probability of having spleentitis.
>> And I want to say normalize, but like
divided by the probability of a positive test result.
>> And what would be, the probabili. The other option is that you
don't have spleentitis.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Even though you got a positive result. And that would be equal to?
>> The probability of a positive result given you don't have spleentitis.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Times the prior probability of not having spleentitis.
>> huh.
>> Divided by the, again the same thing. The probability of the
test results. So that's, those two things added together, needed to be one.
>> Right.
But as you point out. If we just want to figure out which
one is bigger than the other. We don't actually have to know this.
>> Hm, good point.
>> So we can ignore it, okay. Okay, so, let's compute this. So, what
is in fact, the probability of me getting a plus, given that I have spleenitis?
>> Right. So it says in the setup, the
test results correct positive 98% of the time. So,
I, I think that's what it means. It means
that if you really do have it, it's going to
say that you have it with that probability.
>> Okay, so That's just point nine eight. OK? And
that's times the prior probability of having spleentitis which is?
>> .008.
>> Right. .008.
And what's that equal to?
>> It is equal to. 0.0078.
>> 0.00784.
>> Okay, fine. We can do the same thing over here. So
what's the probability of getting a positive if you don't have spleentitis
>> So, the probability of a correct negative is 97%.
That means if you really don't have it, it's going to
say you don't have it, so probability of positive result
given that you don't have it, that should be the 3%.
>> That's exactly right. Times the prior
probability of not having spleentitis which is?
>> .992. 1- .008.
>> That's right, and that is equal to?
>> .02976
>> So, which number is bigger?
>> The one that has the larger significant digit.
>> Which one of those two is that?
>> I mean, obviously, the one that's bigger is the, you don't have it.
>> That's right.
So the answer would be no.
>> And in fact the probability is almost 80%.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is crazy. So, it's like, you go into the doctor, you've run a
test, the doctor says congratulations, you don't
have speentitis, because the test says you do.
>> That's right. [LAUGH]
>> So, what does that tell you?
>> That seems stupid.
>> That does seem stupid, but what does
it tell you About Bayes' Rule. What is
Bayes' Rule capture. What is thing that make
the answer no, despite the fact, you have
a high reliability test that says yes.
>> I. Okay. So I guess, I guess the way to
think about it is, a random person showing up in the
doctors office, is very unlikely to have this particular disease. And
even the tiny, little, small percentage probability that the test would give
a wrong answer is completely swamped by the fact that you
probably don't have the disease. But I guess this isn't really factoring
in the idea that, you know, presumably this lab test was
run for some other reason. There was some other evidence that there
was concern.
>> Or the doctor just really wanted some
more money, because She needs a new boat.
>> Yeah, I know a lot of doctors.
>> I do too.
>> And most of them don't work like that.
>> Yeah most, well most of them have PhD's not MD's. So, another
way of summarizing what you just said Michael, I think, is that priors matter.
>> I want to say the thing that I got out of this is tests don't matter.
>> Well, tests matter.
>> Like what's the purpose of running a
test if if it's going to come back and say.
Well it used to be that I was pretty sure you didn't
have it and now I am still pretty sure you don't have it.
>> Well the point of running a test is
you run a test when you have a reason to
believe that the test might be useful. So what is
the one thing, if I could only change one thing
without getting completely ridiculous, whats the easy well, I
don't know whats easy, whats the easiest thing for me
to change about this setup. I have three numbers here.
This one, this one and this one. What would be
the easiest number to change?
>> Well, in some sense none of the seem
that easy to change but I guess maybe what
you're trying to get me to say is that
if we look at a different population of people
then we can change that .008 number to something
else, like if we only give the test to
people who have other signs of spleentitis. Then then
it, it would probably be a much bigger number.
>> Right, so changing the test, making the test better
might be hard, presumably you know, billion of dollars of
research have gone into that, but if you don't give the
test to people who you don't have any reason to believe
have Spleentitis, just walking off the street, as you put it,
a random person walking off the street, then you can change
the priors, so some other evidence. That you might have splentitis
would lead the prior to change, and then the test would
suddenly be useful. So this, by the way, is an argument
for why you don't want to just require that everyone take
tests for certain things. Because if the prior probability is low, then
the test isn't very useful. On the other hand, as soon as
you have any reason to believe We have strong evidence that someone
might have some condition, then it makes sense to test them for it.
>> So it's like a stop and frisk situation.
>> It's exactly like a stop and frisk
situation. I'm looking at you [INAUDIBLE]. Okay But in
some sense, you're use of the word prior
is a little confusing there. So it's not that
we're changing the prior, it's that we're...we have
some additional evidence that we can factor in. And
I guess we can imagine that that's part
of the prior, but it seems like it's posterior.
>> Yeah, it does. And it, but... One way
to think about it, you actually, I think you
just captured it in what you just said, right?
Which is you can think of as a prior. Well,
a prior to what? So it's your prior belief
over a set of hypotheses, given the world you happen
to be in. If you're in a world where
random people walk in to take a test for splentitis,
then there's a low prior probability that they have it. If you're in a world
where the only people who come in are people who are from a population where
the prior probability is significantly higher, then
you would have a different prior. It's really
a question about where you are in
the process when you actually formulate your question.
>> So would it be worth asking people how, how likely would it have to be
that you have spleentitis to make this test
at all useful? Right, that would change a
positive, a positive result would actually change
your mind about whether someone has it.
>> yeah, actually that, I think that's something that I,
I'll leave for the for the, for the interested reader,
where would that prior probability have to change so that
getting a positive result, I would be more likely to believe
that you actually have it than not. That does bring
up a philosophical question, though, which is So what, just because
the priors have changed, doesn't mean that suddenly the test
is useful, or that the test is going to give you an
answer that somehow distinguishes and is this positive. And from
a mathematical point of view, the question of whether this
number is 0.008 or, or 0.8, you know, 8 10ths
of a percent, where does it change? Does it change
at 5%? Or does it change at 50%? Or does
it change at 500%? It probably changes at 500%. You
know, what, where is the place in which suddenly a
positive result would make you believe they actually had spleentitis or
whatever disease you're looking for. Okay?
>> Okay.